quantum computing for machine learning
is something we're actively looking at
right now it's it's just starting to be
studied for in quantum computing what we
think is possible so we know quantum
computers give exponential speed ups for
problems for example Shor's algorithm
simulation of physical systems the
question is could we get exponential
speed ups for areas of problems in you
know big data learning problems data
analysis problems machine learning and
there we're still actively looking we
have some new results showing that we
can get speed ups quadratic speed ups in
problems like nearest neighbor
classification so various classification
problems and what I like to think in
terms of machine learning and quantum
computing is what questions can we ask
now that we have a quantum computer that
are different from the questions we ask
in machine learning traditionally so now
we have access to new probability
distributions may be new inference
techniques what does that give us for
machine learning it could give us much
better models of users systems you know
whatever we're studying so what I think
is really exciting in the area of
machine learning and quantum computing
is the ability to ask these new
questions not necessarily just look for
these speed ups speed ups might not be
as important as being able to ask a new
question so this could really give a
huge shift in what we can do with
machine learning that's an area we're
really excited about